let's back up I wouldn't have the whole
story on the beginning let's do it
so I was watching the trailer looks
really funny by the way
and Adam Sandler's name was max Kessler
on the trailer
so at first I call my mom I'm like this
is a joke someone dumped the script
someone did something like there's no
way it's my names like it was true it
was real
so I post a picture of myself and Adam
to read it
and it took off and from there he
commented on my facebook profile picture
and the reddit and invited me out here
and the two met for the very first time
during et's interview at the do-over
premiere I got a suit a cutie and her
he's a younger better-looking version
can we bring him over here
let's get him like looking in a mirror
that's our youngest leader better
version of me honestly that must have
blown your mind when you found it his
name was actually max castle I was
really nice I was happy you were happy
that was my favorite part
somebody sent me a clip at my house and
said show me your first thing you did
your thing wasn't as good as the second
yeah you got Owen you got an all cocaine
nothing but everything max did was I was
happy to meet we do everything together
yeah we're besties that's my boy max
think he's moving in goodbye
I already good at basketball that's the
one thing I don't what are you playing
what sporks advanced my home yeah of
course I play whom actually do it if we
play open today you'll come back cool
okay buddy